لكل طائره معايير ومواصفات قياسيه خاصه
يجب ان تتحقق قبل ان يتم السماح لها
بالتحليق حول المعايير والمواصفات
القياسيه المطلوبه من طائره اي 400 سنتعرف
عليها الان مع المهندس
سايمون ني كاسترو وهو مدير برامج اختبار
طائره اي 4 ام التي تنتجها شركه
معنا في عسكريتاريا فيما يتعلق بالمواصفات
والمعايير المطلوبه حتى يتم السماح لطائره
اي 400 ام التحليق ما هي هذه المعايير حتى
تكون الطائره جاهزه للتحليق بشكل امن
مرحبا بكم الى مركز اختبارات التحليق
المدنيه متطلبات المعايير التي يجب ان
تستوفيها طائرات اي 400 ام عاليه ودقيقه
حيث ان الهدف الاساسي من تصميم الطائره هو
للايفاء بمعايير الاعتماد المدنيه وتلك
المعايير توازي معايير الطائرات التجاريه
التي تنتجها ايرباص ولكن علينا ايضا ان
نشمل القدرات العسكريه الهجوميه التي يجب
ان تستوفى بالمواصفات العسكريه الخاصه
بالمعايير العسكريه وقد اتفقنا منذ بدايه
البرنامج على ان العميل هو الذي يحدد
المعايير التي تطبق على الطائره وهذه
المعايير تطبق على تصميم الطائره وادائها
وقدرتها على عكس الطائرات متعدده المحركات
لا تدور محركات طائره اي 400 ام في نفس
الاتجاه اولا ما هو الهدف من هذا الامر
وكذلك كيف يتعامل الطيارين الذين يحلقون
بهذه الطائره مع هذه المساله
تصميم دوران المحركات باتجاهات مختلفه هو
تصميم جديد ويقدم فوائد كبيره خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاداء الهجومي للطائره الفائدتان
الاساسيه هما اولا الكفاءه الديناميكيه
الهوائيه من خلال تحسين التدفق المتناظر
فوق جناح الطائره ما يمكننا من تحسين قدره
الجناح على الحمل وعلاوه على ذلك هناك
فوائد خاصه بزياده السيطره على الطائره
تحت الظروف غير الطبيعيه وفوائد لهيكل
الطائره فيما يخص تاثير عزم الدوران على
هيكل الجناح واجراء مبادلات التصميم
للتعويض عنها انتم في قسم الاختبارات
الهندسيه هل تنتهي علاقتكم بالطائره بعد
ان يتم تسليمها للعملاء ام ان هناك دور
اخر تقومون به بعد تسليم الطائره
بعد تسليم الطائره يقوم العميل باخذ
الطائره الى قاعده تشغيل الطائره الرئيسيه
ومن ناحيه اختبار التحليق فهذه اخر محطه
لتعاملنا مع الطائره الا ان تعاوننا يبقى
وثيقا مع العميل طوال برنامج اختبار
التحليق مؤخرا اجرينا حمله اختبار تحليق
مع بريطانيا حيث زودناهم بالكثير من
المعدات وحلقنا معهم كطاقه من مختلط كجزء
من استعراض تاهيلي وشمل ذلك التزود
بالوقود جوا والتحليقه التلقائي واليدوي
بارتفاعات منخفضه والايصال الجوي